der rechtspopulismus in europa ist also
noch längst nicht besiegt ganz im
gegenteil und auch bei uns wissen sie
geht die diskussion über sogenannte
deutsche werte fröhlich weiter sehen sie
dazu nun eine wie immer feurig
vorgetragene powerpoint präsentation von
nico denz rott rechtsruck in europa wie
kann man das erklären ich versuche es
einfach mal grundsätzlich hier sehen wir
das menschliche leben
auf der einen seite geburt auf der
anderen seite tod dazwischen ganz viel
leere der menschen
diese lehre nicht aus deswegen filter
sie mit quatsch wie es dieser quatsch
organisiert genauso wie andere lebewesen
genauso wie paviane leben wir in gruppen
mit klaren hierarchien um erzählt jemand
quatsch dann sagt jemand anderes genau
ja wohl dass es gesellschaft
jede gesellschaft glaubt an andere
wertes wird immer um werse gestritten
hier sehen wir mal so einen streit hat
man gesehen hier hat man gerade seine
position zur gesellschaft verändert das
ärgert ihr diesen rechten paviane
er ist gegen veränderung und der sagt
das war schon immer so
wir können jetzt einfach mal überprüfen
ob der rechte basieren
recht hat er glaubt daran dass wehrte
sich nicht ändern gucken wir uns einfach
mal das frauenwahlrecht an
auf diesen vier pavian übeln die finnen
haben vorgelegt 1907 um das
frauenwahlrecht eingeführt die deutschen
sind dann 1918 dazu gekommen dann kurz
danach kamen die schweizer und 2002 hat
dann auch bahrain bauen wahlrecht
eingeführt und wenn man sich diese folie
so anguckt dann kann man die schweiz er
dem arabischen kulturraum er rechte
pavian ist jetzt immer noch wütend über
die veränderung jetzt argumentierte wir
sind hier alle seine rechte menschen und
rechte paviane gehen davon aus dass alle
in einer gruppe die gleichen werte haben
und da denke ich jedes mal krass ich hab
doch noch nicht mal die gleichen werte
wie ich selbst
ich betrunken bin habe ich völlig andere
überzeugung als wenn ich nüchtern sind
schon oft ausprobiert aber ich brauche
überhaupt gar keine drogen und mein
werte korsett komplett zu ändern ja so
sieht meine hilfsbereitschaft aus wenn
ich gelassen bin so sieht sie aus
wenn ich müde bin hungrig gestresst und
hier sieht man das ist dann sogar
negative hilfsbereitschaft verhält sich
dann anderen menschen nicht über die
straße sondern stellen ein bein
das heißt wenn mich jemand fragt an
welche werte glaubst du dann ist meine
gegenfrage und wie viel uhr
ich bin auch sehr davon überzeugt dass
wahlen komplett anders ausgehen würden
wenn man die wahllokale nur zwischen 4
und 5 uhr nachts öffnen würde
während sich das leben so anguckt dann
besteht das leben immer aus veränderung
das ist gerade das kennzeichen von leben
das sich werte verändern das sieht man
hier die einzige zustand in dem sich
werte nicht ändern ist wenn man tot ist
so gesehen wobei das stimmt nicht ganz
selbst leichen verändern sich ja noch im
verwesungsprozess so gesehen sind selbst
tote lebendiger als das weltbild der afd
[Applaus]
immer dieses langweilige afb bashing ich
krieg natürlich auch sehr viel feedback
von asd anhänger nicht weiter unter
anderem als system bezeichnet die sich
vom system parteien finanzieren lässt
und das möchte ich hier jetzt mal
klarstellen wer mich tatsächlich
finanziert das sind grob gesehen drei
institutionen zu 58 prozent finanziert
mich mama hört sich prozent papa und was
viele spd anhänger sicher nicht
überraschen wird für zwei prozent werden
meine gags finanziert vom syrischen
verein zur vernichtung des deutschen
volkes
[Applaus]